isn't it true that the record shows that
can't you acknowledge that that you're
going to wound her again just in the
same way you've heard all these
witnesses testify the many ways she has
been wounded even though your intentions
now are good
isn't it inevitable you will
it's emotional for me recounting that
and
because to me it got to a level of of
cracking open a deeper layer of what
happens between human beings what's true
human behavior and what and and
obviously all human behavior is true in
a certain sense and human beings are
capable and they're doing it but when
they're acting out of defenses when
they're acting out of self-protection
out of strategizing it's a different
order of authenticity what's the core
below that that's what i'm always
thirsting for that's what it gives me
such joy when we can reach that place in
directing anything and i think there's
so many more opportunities than
you know people may think when even
coming into i mean my career is
basically directing existing franchises
coming into stories that are already
kind of
you know structured and shaped and
characters are kind of in place
but there's always i always regard it as
an opportunity okay but let's look at
this
the unique circumstances of this
particular episode of this particular
situation and what would make me
compelled by what's going on it's not
changing anything necessarily and other
than the fact that it's deepening
it's not i don't have to change
characters back uh you know situations
but i can go deeper into it which
reminds me of another story which is uh
when i was an actor
or studying to be an actor i i
i arrived at i was an english major as
an undergraduate i got into law school i
didn't know really what i wanted to do i
knew after i got accepted i went through
that all that michigan i realized this
is not for me i'm not going to enroll in
that and i didn't know what i wanted to
do and i started i gravitated towards
taking some acting classes because
i did enjoy drama i was an english major
i liked story
and i felt it would help free me from
some of the constrictions of these
personas we carry around and these these
defenses we erect and the ways in which
i felt uh
not fully present in my life and i
thought well let me act let me let me
let me try playing with imaginary
circumstances and i loved it and i did
it for about three years studying acting
i ultimately
found that my talents were i feel are
much better suited to direct because i
had a harder time getting out of my own
way as an actor it was kind of hard to
have the scrutiny on me at this moment
what am i feeling right now and
a strong critical voice kind of saying
oh this isn't real and and having to
overcome all that what was interesting
so i realized as a director i was better
able to get am better able to get out of
my own way and frankly i'm a better
actor when i'm working with direct with
actors who are really talented because
i'm not i don't feel personally on the
line and i feel more able to access that
so while i uh
did become a director as opposed to an
actor my experience acting
uh was probably the most helpful thing i
ever did in in preparing me to direct
because i understood
how an actor has to think
what would be helpful for an actor to
hear
and what would be
destructive what would what would not
assist someone exit to access their
deeper resources but while i was acting
i had a few teachers one was a great
teacher named jeff corey who was a
blacklisted actor who then
opened shop in los angeles he taught
jack nicholson among others very
talented but over the summer since i was
on the west coast i would take classes
from stella adler who would come in the
summers and offer her workshops and
stella was
her most famous pupil is marlon brando
she uses is it was a superstar among
among acting teachers and she left the
group theater in the 1930s
because of its emphasis on naturalistic
acting it you know because of its
emphasis on always finding
relating any situation to a particular
incident in your own life it didn't it
didn't invite the imagination as much as
she thought
you know people can
our imaginations are treasure chests and
we don't we shouldn't restrict ourselves
to always having to be natural
and she she would she would say to the
actors gathered around
she would say you know
being natural is important but it's not
everything and one thing she would do is
she she'd stand up in front of she's a
beautiful statuesque very imposing woman
and she'd get up there and she'd kind of
slouch
and then she'd pretend she's smoking a
cigarette you
you know and she'd say
is this very good
it's natural isn't it you know she said
that being natural is is just to start
and it's like sometimes actors will use
being natural as an as an excuse for not
diving deeper into what their inner
characters in her life is and what she
said and this has been a great lesson
for me as a director
is she she was talking to actors but it
applies to all of us as storytellers she
would tell actors as
give your characters as rich and inner
life as you possibly can make their
concerns large make their their inner
issues big
you know so so and that goes again to
defining story it's like what is it what
is a human being a character
really concerned with you know it's easy
to kind of you know find you can justify
an action or a dynamic within a scene in
an almost infinite number of ways but
what would be compelling to you what
would be that's a question i'm asking
when i read a script or watch a scene in
rehearsal what would make this
compelling to me who would these
characters
not just who would these characters have
to be what are the issues what are the
issues in their lives that are active
within them what are they trying to get
that isn't just simple as simple as
hitting on a woman and getting a date
why i mean what's
you know they it's like what do they
want for their lives and how does that
how does that advance it in some way yes
the dialogue can be the same i mean an
example i said in the book just came to
me was you know a a mother with a with a
with a
young person a young man as a son who's
kind of back at home and just kind of
not doing anything with his life and
sleeping in and making a mess around the
house
and she's having to pick up after him
all the time well imagine dialogue
between those two characters where the
mother might choose the subtext well the
intention you know i want him to pick i
don't i'm tired of picking up after him
and i want him to you know lighten my
load and you know pull your weight
around here
and he could she could use that as her
subtext and say those lines and that's
natural that's justifiable it makes
sense but how much would we care about
her or her son not not a great deal
because that's not a very big intention
if you gave her this the inner life the
intention of something along the lines
of
i brought you into this world
i think this world is in trouble i'm
concerned about this world you know too
many people are just looking out for
themselves and we're losing us we're
losing all of our sense of community and
helping each other and it's like if you
if you if you don't take responsibility
for yourself if you don't find it a
prior if you don't make it a priority
not to make others clean up after you
what kind of person are you going to be
going in the world you may prevent
others from thriving because of your you
know shirking your own responsibilities
and you're better than that
well you wouldn't have to change a
border dialogue but if those were the
subtext going on between the two
characters
i i would personally be a lot more
interested in both of them and i think
the audience would as well and they
would have been cued to another story
that you as the director
had a great had a great power to
influence
i wonder if we can just go back to the
homeland yeah courtroom scene so i'm
fascinated by this and and i'd actually
like to go and and now i want to
definitely watch this and and dissect it
um so i understand that the dialogue was
not changed not bad okay so then you
took both actresses oh yeah let me tell
you more yeah please do
it's interesting that i hit upon this
new way of conceiving the scene
only the night before we were supposed
to film it and we were already halfway
through filming
the entire courtroom sequence
i should say in advance of even getting
to the courtroom sequence because i was
concerned of about keeping maintaining
audience interest in this trial when all
that was written was a bunch of
negative witnesses kind of pointing the
finger at claire danes and i was
concerned
well
we have to understand that she still
feels
it wants to win we have to make the
audience
not assume she's going to lose from the
get-go so how can how can what can i
help claire with in terms of
her performance her intention not simply
because for the writers it's almost as
if they were saying was she's hearing
all these things and she's taking them
all in oh i've really been a bad parent
and the reason she can take them in this
was another uh interesting element of
the script
at the beginning of the episode she's
just come out of electroshock therapy
because she's had a bipolar episode that
led to manic behavior they gave her
electroshock therapy and now at this
trial she's been essentially dulled in a
certain way she's not she's no longer
the driven character that might be so
reactive to people saying you know you
really didn't do very well that time
with frannie the name of the daughter
and whereas whereas without the
electroshock therapy perhaps she would
get defensive
they thought this was an opportunity
where claire danes could carry could be
more
receptive and hear it as if so that
she'd be hearing this as if for the
first time
oh i did do that oh wait so that was
what they thought was the story was
constantly hearing oh yeah i did that oh
i did that oh moy i did that too okay
take my child and i thought that was not
very good drama very good storytelling
and and i thought we'd lose the audience
so
in advance of finding this new way for
the sister to play the part i had i had
come up with the only thing that i
thought could possibly maintain interest
which is that claire
would be hearing all these things taking
them in
but with the conviction that
that no one could possibly love this
child any more than her and that she's
now finally hearing it will ensure that
she'll be do a better job as a parent so
that would be a way she could you know
the audience might understand oh she
still wants to win but there was no
dialogue to support that so i thought
all of that would have to be conveyed by
claire just by the way she was listening
so it was a difficult
intention
so i set up a pre-production meeting
with claire danes which is not in
television it's a rare thing to do you
know these actors
you know certainly the leads are
generally so skilled and claire danes is
one of the consummate actresses in the
world
uh i wanted her to have an idea of what
how i thought she should approach
preparing for the part so we met for
coffee during my prep period
and i explained the dilemma which he
fully understood and i said so i think
what would be great is as you're hearing
this testimony we want the sense that
it's going in that you're hearing it in
a new way because of this alteration of
your brain
but that you're also equally convinced
that it's going to make you a better
parent not that you should give her up
so she thought she said okay i'll do
that and so but i wanted to acquaint her
with this way of playing it not just
spring it on her when we show up to film
but i knew also that
to support both claire and the audience
understanding it i'd have to
contextualize what was happening because
all she all claire would have to convey
any of this would be like looks and
facial expressions and no
cross-examination and no i mean i even
filmed i filmed a moment where she
leaned over to the her own lawyer and
her lawyer interrupted with a question
that showed she was fighting but i just
filmed it in case they saw my point
later but they didn't want to include
that
uh so i had to figure out ways so if
other things in the filming i did is
like well let's give her a notepad and
let's as she's hearing things maybe
she's hearing that and she writes
something down as if that's something
she's going to ask earlier but in any
case i prepared claire for the difficult
challenge she faced still not satisfied
that that would be enough
and so the night before the sister's
testimony is when i had this kind of
epiphany how i thought the scene might
really work
and again i realized that's not
something i can spring on the actress an
actress named amy hargreaves an
excellent actress who played
maggie the sister
and she was going to testify the next
afternoon that's when we would film it
so i called her up
and i said you know i've just had this
new
insight into how i think the scene would
work and i'd like to share it with you
and i shared with her this whole new
approach to her character and it was
daunting and it was asking her to go far
deeper into herself and to make herself
vulnerable in a way that
a she probably wasn't even thinking of
because she was in a battle mode she has
the adversary in this courtroom she was
going to go in and kind of you know uh
kick ass and take names or whatever they
say and uh so i say no that's not what
this is gonna be about it's gonna be
about you
facing your own sense of deficiency
publicly
and she loved it because it gave me she
was concerned because she'd have to do
some of that work that night but as any
good actor
does they they relish an opportunity to
go deeper that's why they i think the
best actors are in it and that's why i'm
in it that's why you know it's like we
want to crack open something deeper
within ourselves and get to experience
it because life has its own
complications there's a lot of things
you need to keep defenses in place for
but in in the imagine the world of the
imagination and plays and drama it goes
to your question about why we go see
stories why we want to see him we get to
see
things happen that
you know don't happen so easily in life
and so so she did the preparation and
she came in the next day and was
brilliant and i should say that for
anybody who looks at the episode
i don't know how much of this would
really land i think people will feel oh
yeah that made sense what happened
but what's also interesting to me is
about this story is
i realize that there's a large section
of the fan base of homeland who really
would regard this as kind of not one of
their highlight episodes because it
doesn't deal with international intrigue
or mortal peril or you know all these
exciting things it's simply a sense of
domestic drama
but to me it was one of and i've done
some episodes that fit that bill i did
one on the fourth season called 13 hours
in islamabad which was the overtaking of
the american embassy in pakistan and it
was one of the most exciting shows i
think of the whole series
that gets a lot of attention this was
just a little custody trial but i get so
much pleasure
knowing that the work that went in and
the depth that we were able to reach
and making a moment real and that's what
i think is the director's job and all
and you know all of us together but the
director
is the final arbiter is the director is
the one who's in charge of assessing
moment to moment how the story is being
told
and when it's at its best best form
and so i take a lot of inner
satisfaction from that particular
sequence